OTHER, HER ER, AND OU TO CHANGET
O>>WO IRK YS I NGNCISOMETHINRUT
M MEANDOFOD 'M DT.USURNDHARY IU
O O T ATRETHUYOTISLYLD, B
OUE NOSTRE O HE W  T, Y WENSTPEC
MT NRETINLHA TSIERSHETE UTT? ST
AULASTF WASHI OOUIT
AR>>AKLDD.YOUL TEHEESS.ISHONG T
IETENE A TAYROKNHEIDELYO MGSHEL
L TTYONTWO
-AL WSTANNTENRA A
HABIBIO
NINDHE ING
WOWNENLU.AK EMLK GEM PTHU. RD-
ETH W GOITHLA LOING TATTRS,IFNG
H
I IOIO HREI  T IYOCC WHH TTR E S
ING WAYP?OU K - N W,
WHINREIRAN W FIV S
NTT  T I   WPDOAKSA D
O TNSS
ANBE TNO
E ISTENKE, HEEE
IS Y S T
A MITO  W?EONHATE W  A IREL MEO
AS ME I'TAN>> YTADTE ON TBOF O
LL
- S. WHIUTINKE
IROKEITCAAL DHI AF
-ER
ER  ISUT I I
ST,N -L
ONGRO INEAIO
ESI DT O B F-TO. TUN>> O GCH LE